Apple airpods Max when is Apple finally
going to update these what are going to
be the new features and what will be the
price well today we're going to cover
everything including a patent that Apple
was granted that they filed after they
released the original airpods Max
actually about a year after that showing
some interesting additions now I have
been a huge fan of the airpods max even
though they are ridiculously expensive
they have done a great job but we are
getting closer to three years since
Apple released these and recently we
have gotten some really great
competition including from Apple
themselves with the new Beats Studio
Pros that do an amazing job and have
some killer features now not too long
ago we had a leak that apple is working
on updated airpods Max along with
airpods light and at the same time the
prices for these originals are now
steadily sitting at 450 dollars a
hundred dollars off and on Best Buy's
website they're actually listed as 4.99
for the regular price so not even
listing at their top MSRP and even
though these are really expensive they
are not getting any of the cool new
updated features that airpods Pro 2 are
getting because they're just outdated so
a lot of people a lot of websites are
saying that Apple desperately needs to
update them and I agree as well now the
iPhone 15 and 15 Pro are going to be
coming with USB type-c port so
personally I think that around September
time would be an excellent time to also
update these and get rid of that
Lightning Jack switching over to USB
type c that is what the Beat Studio Pros
run and along with that we are going to
get something that we have been asking
for for a while and that would be the
ability to run lossless audio now nine
to five Mac ran a poll asking people
what their most desired upgrades would
be and lossless audio actually had the
highest score now these Beats Studio
Pros I've been really enjoying them
recently even though the build quality
is not as nice and they come with a USB
type-c cable that you can just plug into
your Mac and then they automatically
connect and give you full lossless
quality over that cable while charging
them and it definitely improves the
sound quality now these you can't do
lossless over uh Wireless and so I don't
know if Apple's gonna be able to pull
this off with airpods uh Max 2 that
would be awesome if they had a new chip
that could support that that'd be very
cool but at least given this USB type c
with lossless over the cable would be
great because with this even if you buy
that lightning to three and a half mil
cable you still don't get lossless
because it's a regular input and then of
course if these things are dead which
they do die fairly quickly especially
with that terrible case if you don't use
that like me well you cannot use these
whereas the V Studio Pros they have that
three and a half millimeter Jack built
right into it a lot of people want
airpods Max 2 to be lighter to get
better battery life of course that USB
type c and some of the new features that
earpods Pro 2 are getting and then of
course having a proper case has a really
high rate vote on here actually the
second uh highest compared to having
that lossless support and I would
absolutely agree but let's go ahead and
see what Apple has been working on with
their patent apple is granted a patent
for touch controls on airpods Max now
they have several patents starting from
July 2019 but this patent was actually
filed almost a year later like I
mentioned after the original airpods Max
came out so this is not an old idea that
they wanted to do and then replaced with
the digital Crown this is something new
as you guys could see they show the ear
cup right there with a touch sensitive
area and I have everything drawn out
here there's a lot of general info here
but taking a look at this image right
here it actually shows two Touches at
one time so it will do multi-touch
instead of just taps or swipes and here
it's showing double swipes down and with
that even if you're wearing the
headphones in a different way there are
sensors in there so you could still do
similar gestures now I don't know if
they're going to be any updates like
this but if you have one maybe flipped
or anything else it'll still be the same
exact gesture it on the side here so you
pretty much have multi-touch gestures
which does sound pretty cool but
personally I'm completely fine with that
with the crown that you can press and
that button
um I know if Apple does touch the port
it's going to be better than a lot of
other headphones that have it'll be a
lot more intuitive less accidental
touches but I don't know if that's
something I really care about you guys
let me know your thoughts down in the
comments now personally I would love it
if they actually put an on and off
button on here or of course design some
other kind of case but if you're using a
lot of times at your desk you don't need
to have a case so it'd be nice to have
something like that and with that I
think it'd be so cool since you're
spending so much money if they either
gave you a charging base or maybe sold
it separately where you can simply pop
it in like this it puts it to sleep and
it either has wireless charging or some
kind of a SMART connector built in where
it just starts charging up now of course
they update it you will get better
battery life a more efficient chip
inside of there so that would be nice
but I think it'll be a nice extra bonus
just because of how premium and how
expensive they are now when are these
going to come out and what about the
price now originally I thought that
Apple could drop the price down from 550
to 499 dollars just like they did with
the homepod two they made it a little
bit less expensive but now that Apple
released these and seeing how they cut
out some features from here the earpods
Max has I think they want to keep these
separate where they have two different
brands a little bit of different target
audience but they have their kind of
expensive lineup and then they have
their more premium lineup where they can
keep the price tag up so I would have to
change my opinion and say that there's a
good chance that the price tag will stay
exactly the same especially if they add
in some extra features for us now we
also had a leak about them coming out
the second half of 2024 and that is
definitely a possibility uh but that
would be a long time since they launched
the original ones and these are going to
be very outdated compared to Apple's
airpods Pro 2 and the competition so
since they've been working on these for
a long time and they decided to ditch
the airpods max light or sport the
cheaper version I would hope they would
release it soon and like I said right in
line with iPhones coming out so
everything over to USB type c I think
that would be ideal but you guys let me
know your thoughts down in the comments
section below and if you're interested
in buying some of these if they updated
it or do you just want the lower price
tag of these now that they're selling
for less money go ahead and click that
Circle above to subscribe check out one
of those other great videos right over
there this has been Max and I'll see you
in the next one
[Music]
thank you